Vous avez cliqué une fois de plus,
vous avez envie de vous faire peur.
Et alors, c'est parti on est là pour ça mon gars !
Épisode 4 d'Outlast 2
allez c'est ti-par mon gars.
Là, je sais pas ce qu'il nous attend mais...
Parfait ! Parfait !
Mais c'est parfait !
J'allais vous dire au moment où il s'est mis à dire ça j'allais vous dire...
Eh mais il faudrait qu'on trouve cette mine et ces montagnes où elle est censé être.
"Babylone"
C'est quoi ce truc qui s'est déverrouillé "Babylone"
Ah c'est par là pardon, autant pour moi.
C'est parfait !
Je rêvais de trouver cette mine et de rejoindre les gens qui ont sauvés ma femme et qui donc vont peut être me sauver aussi.
Quoi?
Pourquoi j'ai eu mal?
Attend c'est quoi ce délire là?
Cactus ! D'accord faut faire gaffe aux cactus, ça marche.
...ça... me va !
Est-ce que je me bande du coup ?
Non c'est bon j'ai pas assez mal au point de me bander.
Attend le détail du cactus c'est abusé quand même.
Une feuille ?
Ma chère...
Ma plus grande bien aimé.
Ma compagne intime la plus fidèle...
Oh putain... Je sais pas ce que ça raconte mais...
C'est très très long,
Et moi j'ai juste envie de rejoindre Linda
Ou Lynn,
c'est pas Linda c'est Lynn, pourquoi je dis ça... ?
Oh ! Nouvelle maison ?
On peut toquer ou quelque chose, vous pensez ?
Ah bah... on peut sauter apparemment. On peut s'infiltrer chez cette personne apparemment.
Damn it!
Ah Jessica s'est pendue !
En fait, d'accord.
D'accord.
Damn it ! Ok en fait, Jess s'est pendue c'est ça ? D'accord.
ah non, il parle de la vision qu'il a eu de Lynn pendue. Ah j'sais pas putain
j'ai du mal a suivre bordel, j'ai du mal à suivre
en fait, j'ai tellement peur, je suis tellement en stress dans ce jeu
que j'ai du mal à... à me souvenir de l'histoire, des prénoms, des trucs c'est horrible
ooh, ça c'est vraiment pas cool ça... c'est vraiment pas cool...
des casiers qui bougent tout seuls ca fait plaisir personne...
Ah ! J'espérais que ce soit verrouillé pour une fois, tu vois.
j'espérais que cette put*** de porte soit verrouillée. C'est pas le cas.
on est mal
ooh, non...
des bugs comme ça c'est vraiment pas beau. C'est vraiment pas sympa.
Ah ! C'est un peu ouvert
il y avait une ombre... il y avait une ombre, je te le jure j'ai vu une ombre
je vous dirai pas pourquoi mais j'ai vu une ombre
et ça, ça me scandalise légèrement
c'est quoi ça ?
Ah !
C'est un pendu, on joue au pendu
"_ _ _O_ _ _V_ _LE"
oh, put*** mec j'aime pas quand la cam elle fait cet effet
oh ! Il y avait une ombre là, derrière la porte
j'ai cru voir un truc passer
mec, je deviens parano sa mère... je deviens totalement parano. C'est scandaleux à quel point je deviens parano
on n'apprécie pas
Personne, ok
bon ben, on fait le tour hein.
on continue. Bloquée... et bloquée
P*tain mais y a combien il y a de salle de cours là ?
oh, il y a une note.
ouhla...
Ah, j'aurais peut-être dû filmer le truc du pendu avec le caméra, ça aurait peut-être fait un *incompréhensible*
Ooh
ah ok, c'est un truc transparent pour mettre sur un projecteur ok.
du coup, si je mets ça là dessus... Hop !
voilà, on a une première partie
Uuh eun rgi rab
c'est la suite "UNF  RGI  AB"
il nous faut le deuxième
aaaah ok, faut juste maintenir et... D'accord faut l'décaler.. Très bien !
Moi j'cherchais un deuxième truc. Je me suis fais des idées.
et maintenant il faut l'avancer
Et ça va compléter les lettres
"impardonnable"
"UNFORGIVABLE"
d'accord mais qu'est-ce qui s'est passé pour qu'elle se tue au fait ? Quel est le bordel ? Quel est le fu** ?
faut que j'aille où... ? Là bas ? Bon bas on retourne sur nos pas hein
Mais il y avait l'autre coté couloir
Ah voilà par là
Oulah...
ah bah non...
Damn it !
aaaaah ok, nouvelle porte on est bien
et des casiers, une sauvegarde ça nous fait pas plaisir ça
ok c'est à nous.. Oh ! Il y a un truc qui a apparut
il y a une ombre (x2) Vous la voyez des fois
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'ce bordel ?
*Cris*
j'en peux plus...
je peux même pas me bander...
allez (x2)
allez vas-t'en !
vas-t'en ! Je peux pas !
oh, les pu***
avec cette ombre de me*** là
maudit sois-tu
ah là il y a une salle... ok fallait que j'aille par là
Damn it ! Ah oui ok j'ai compris, j'y vais.
Comment ça je peux pas y aller ? Oh put***...
ah, faut que je mette un truc, ok
Gnééééhé
je veux pas qu'le monstre il revienne, il m'a fait peur
allez go. ok on est dedans (x2), on est bien (x2) il viendra jamais ici mec
quelle créature serait assez.. oh p*tain j'ai cru que c'étais quelque chose devant
Mais clairement
ah mais mec t'es entrain de perdre la tête tout simplement
Whaaat ?
p**tain ! Comme sa part en steaks
Le mec devient complètement fou, il devient barré mon gars
Il devient complètement barré
Ok donc je vous rappelle qu'on est entrain de rejoindre les mines.
Et de rejoindre notre gow bien-sûr
La corniche
Wouaahou c'est chaud là.
C'est là-haut faut qu'on aille ? Dans les maisons qu'il y a là-haut vous pensez ?
Ouais je pense.
P***tain j'ai hâte d'y aller quoi de découvrire la suite là
Et de retrouver ma femme ! et voir heuu
Ce qu'elle est devenue. J'suis sûr le bébé il va.. ça va être un gros prématuré ça va être un démon t'sais quand il va naître.
Oh p*tain. Oooh !!
Aaah mais oui j'ai jamais été très fort pour ça
Mais oui regarde pas en bas. Regarde tout droit voiiila
Cette là-bas juste là-bas. On y est presque, en vrai.
Par contre ça si sa craque, on est vraiment heuu.. en PLS
Il y avait un train avant. P*****.
Ok
Wouaaa tous les insectes !
Whaaaaat ?
Ok. Ah yes il a un truc à dire
*Cris ou grognement*
Noooooon
Ah les abeilles de m*rde ptn. En plus c'est frustrant on saura même pas ce que le rush vidéo que j'étais entrain de prendre
C'était la mine au loin j'aurais dû la filmer ptn
Raah les abeilles ptnnn elles ont pas aimé mon vlog.
Elles m'ont pas laissé vlogger
Oh nan oh noon
Ah mais attend en fait j'suis pendu par les pieds
Et j'ai plus ma caméra elle est devant moi
*chuchotement* Whaaat the ?
*chuchotement* Whaaaaat ?
Je peux descendre peut-être ou pas là ?
faut que je me balance. Si c'est bon.
Aaah j'ai fait tellement de bruit.
Ah p*tain.
Le chef de la secte là, Knoth faut le tuer quoi.
Allez j'ai ma caméra. Si j'ai ma caméra ça va.
Ooh p*tain.
On dirait bien ouais.
T'as raison.
Bon bah c'est par là hein clairement.
On se balade.
Hop.
Petit parcours, on est bien.
P*tain
Oh, une note.
Prend-la !
"Cette lave à ... cette bénédiction pour un malade à essayer de partir.. et je l'ai brisé ne répétez pas ses erreurs et ne commettez pas ses péchés."
Ok d'accord.
Mais un moment heu je vais faire comme lui.
Je vais me barrer.
Niquel allez, la branche (x3)
Aller, aller. Il y a personne derrière. On est bien.
Le mec arrive à marcher sur une planche en se retournant, il est très très chaud.
Allez on est bien.
On y croit. On va rejoindre la mine, on va être sauvé par nos potos de la mine, qui ont sauvé notre femme avant nous.
C'est des gens bien.
On sait pas pourquoi ils habitent aussi proche de cette secte.
Mais ils, ils l'ont sauvée.
Allez.
*gros bruit*
J'ai pas vu. (x2)
Qu'est-ce qu'il s'est passé ?
Comment ça "mon Dieu" ?
J'ai même pas compris pourquoi il a dit "Oh mon Dieu".
J'ai pas compris.
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a ? Y a un mec là qui me suit ? Qu'est-ce qu'il se passe la ?
ça pue le screamer ça hein.
Bon, faut se barrer d'ici.
Faut partir
Damn it !
*son de dégout de notre cher Squeezie*
puuuuuuuuuta*n
Bah on prend l'autre chemin, qui est le chemin des cascadeurs.
Mais là, p*tain on descend trop là.
Faut qu'on monte nous, pas qu'on descende.
houlà on voit rien.
Une note.
Et je parle pas du maiître de la secte, mdr (Knoth/note) c'est hyper drôle.
"Bienvenue dans ce lieu de guérison spirituelle, vous avez peur ...
...vous avez peur et vous êtes malade. Comme vous devriez l'être.
Et vous êtes rempli de honte. Vous avez raison de l'être. Vous...." P*tain... mais mec
Oh *surpris*
Mais il va me défoncer lui.
Il mange un mec là ? Nan. P*tain on dirait Gollum de ouf.
Incroyable, elle va se vénére contre moi je vais devoir courir.
OOOHOH
Méchante femme.
*encore surpris* OHOOOHO
Il m'as vomis dessus. *dégout*
Ah mais p*tain ces des lépreux de ouf en fait.
Ok faut que j'aille par là-bas.
Faut que je passe à coté, que je les ignore.
Olàlà je suis au milieu des tarés mon gars.
Oooh il avait une batte !
OOOOH
Vite la porte !
Mais j'suis con c'est pas par là.
C'est par là. Raah p*tain.
*surpris*
Oh ça a escaladé très vite là, le taux de glauquitude... du... du délire.
C'est où ? (x2)
C'est où la vidéo ? Elle s'est déclenchée à quel moment, j'ai pas compris.
Bon tant pis, j'ai écouter le rec qui a genre buggé, j'ai pas réussi à retrouver l'endroit. Ça fais ch*er.
Heu je fais quoi là ? Une fois que je suis là ?
Ça mène... C'est carrément un cul-de-sac ça en fait...
Ah mais c'est là ! P*utain y avait un mur ok en haut de la...
...de la p*tain de colline j'avais pas vu...
Y a beaucoup de sang d'ailleurs, je suis pas le premier à m'enfuir par là
Allez p'tite corniche
Pfff wouahou
Allez on peut le faire
We can do it easy. Easy !
Voilà !
On suit le sang en fait
OOOH *surpris*
Chier !
Rooh p*tain !
Ohlàlàlàlà y a des bruits mec de...
Ah les bonnes lunettes, il a toujours des lunettes le mec dans... dans Outlast quoi
Mais c'est quoi ça ?!
Oh mais c'est le.. le mec qui est sur gros truc !
Par là !
Par là ! (x3)
Pas par là ! (x3) Pas par là du tout !
Là j'suis b**sé ! Bon j'vais m'soigner hein ...
Faut qu'j'aille par où ?
Faut qu'j'aille de là ou il vient, ça c'est sûr !
Ok go !
P*utain ils me lancent quoi ? Ils me lancent des cailloux ? C'est quoi qu'ils me lancent
Allez on va le fuir...
Let's go, on l'fuit !
Trace !
Fils de p*te ! "Q" !
Dégage !
Et voilà du coup, on est perdus ! Ah nan c'est bon c'est par là !
Là là là, j'avais pas vu !
Allez !
What the fuck ?? Y avait Hitman devant l'casier mon gars
Bon bah sortons hein...
Vas-y sortons hein
Oh p*tain
Jeeeess ??!
J'te suis Jess
Elle est où ?
Là y a un PC
On peut aller... OH !
On ! "Père Porcari, J'ai fais sortir Mlle GRAY de la classe d'éducation physique aujourd’hui afin d'avoir une petite discussion avec elle...
Père Loutermilch s'inquiète du fait qu'elle soit un peu trop sensible pour son propre bien..."
Oooooh y a des p*tain de mails...
"Jessica Gray fiels trip" ok...
"Je sais que vous avez rencontré son père et sa grande personnalité, et ce qui est arrivé à sa mère est une grande tragédie, que Dieu ait son âme...
...Quoi qu'il en soit, le Père Loutermilch pense que cela ne serait pas une bonne idée de laisser Jessica à participer à l'excursion à l'usine de piano...
...et je suis plutôt d'accord avec lui. Elle présente les caractéristiques d'un enfant prêt à fuguer."
"En plus de cela, la signature de son père sur la feuille de permission est gênante, tant il est évident qu'elle l'a falsifiée...
...J'ai donc besoin de votre permission pour suspendre cette autorisation ; nous la placerons en étude à la bibliothèque ce jour-là"
Ooh la pauvre...
Ok
Donc elle rate une bonne sortie scolaire euh cool, très bien
Par là ?
Ok... Encore un endroit...
Ça fait longtemps que j'ai pas trouvé de pile, il me faudrait une pile
Ah ! Les toilettes !
Les fucking toilets
Oh p*tain j'ai cru qu'il y allait avoir un screamer dans les toilettes
J'me suis dit ils auraient pas osé
Ils ont quand même pas osé
Nan ils ont pas osé, c'est bien...
Bon bah ça nous avance pas sur euh le.. la trajectoire
Oh j'l'ai pris en vidéo ça ?
'Tain dès que je prends une vidéo quand on est dans cet endroit...
Ça marche pas...
C'est bizarre quand même
Si j'viens vers toi tu vas pas m'manger ?
Oh p*taiiiin !
J'pars pas j'suis là ! C'est toi qui part
Oh là là...
Oh p*tain  !
J'suis où là ?
D'accord ! On repasse dans les...
P*tain mais les transitions elles sont incroyables mon gars !
Oh là là là là...
Donc Jess s'est suicidée, elle est pendue...
On a vu qu'elle était euh... qu'elle était suspendue d'une euh...
Oh merde...
*pleurs exagérés de Squeezie*
D'accord...
Mais t'y crois c'est bien, c'est bien..
Naaan !
Nan !
Naaaaan !
Fuck !
Oh p*tain !
Les mecs sont complètement barrés mon gars. C'est... (x2)
P*tain mec qu'est-ce tu veux que je fasse, j'suis cloué à un p*tain de croix quoi... ?
Qu'est-ce tu veux que je fasse ?
Oh naaaaan !
Oh p*tain !
Oh p*tain ! Normalement ça t'arrache toute la main
Ah bah ouais ouais...
Mais j'vais mettre un bandage et ça ira mieux, t'inquiètes pas
Regarde...
Mais... *rires* "Vous n'avez pas de bandages"
"Vous saignez, vous avez besoin de bandage" Ouais mais j'en ai pas
Faut qu'j'trouve un... Il faut que je trouve un... un bandage
Là j'suis obligé d'aller à gauche...
Super ! Bon... Il me faut un bandage là !
P*tain ça fait longtemps que j'ai pas **** de bandage
Oh p*taiiiiin... J'vais m'faire one shot
J'ai plus ma caméra... J'ai plus rien !
Vas-y hein, faut tenter une direction hein...
Eh ben voilà !
Là là là
Aller saute !
Ah putain !
Mais non !
Oh naaan !
Oh j'suis vraiment obligé de trouver un bandage quoi !
Oh meeeerde
Faut que j'trouve un bandage !
Excusez moi est-ce que quelqu'un vend un bandage contre 3... ?
Fils de p*te.
Naaaaaaan !
J'avais trouvé le bandage ! J'étais prêt à me bander.
p*taiiiiiin.
Oh y en a un là !
C'est bon j'en ai un !
Yes ! J'en ai trouver un autre.
Attends faut que je me barre parce que je sais pas si y a pas un mec qui est entrain de me suivre.
Je vais le mettre là pépére derrière cette arbre !
Mets le bandage (x2)
Voiiiiiila.
ça va aller (x2)
Voiiiiiiiiila. On est bieeen ! (x2)
ça fait le taff, un petit bandage..
ça guérit tout seul après.
*ris du nez*
Oh mec.
Ok maintenant je sais où je dois aller.
P*tain je m'obstinais à aller chercher le.. un bandage qui été a droite.
Je vais vous montrez où il était.
Allez Go